tandis qu'à dans l'île voisine de la
martinique un appel est lancé pour la
sauvegarde du patrimoine architectural
d'un quartier de fort de france devant
la poussée de l'immobilier les vieilles
maisons dites maison folle construite
dans les années 20 disparaissent les
unes après les autres
celui qui distribue des tracts aux
automobilistes aux hommes politiques
viennent montplaisir agi dit-il
aujourd'hui d'abord en simple citoyen
français du patrimoine son combat sans
vie cette maison de la route de didier
mieux connu sous le nom de chypre une
bâtisse qui date des années quand et qui
surprend par son architecture
il nous revient qu'effectivement ces
prisons dont le conseil régional a fait
l'acquisition ferait partie d'un projet
de construction de musées qui
nécessiterait dit-on sa destruction sans
cesse sollicités par des promoteurs
immobiliers qui leur font des offres
alléchantes
les propriétaires craquent les uns après
les autres mais il y a les résistants
qui traînent amoureux de cette maison
comme de toutes les vieilles maisons
coloniales et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai fait inscrire cette maison
à l'inventaire des monuments historiques
ce qui est certain qu'on traite
mais ce qui est sûr qu'elle sera
préservé pas facile en effet de garder
ses maisons en bon état
coût de rénovation élevé problèmes
d'indivision faut qu'elles sont vides
abandonnées dans certains cas la drac
les collectivités locales apportent une
aide aux propriétaires risi c'est une
véritable prise de conscience que yan
monplaisir invite les martinique dans
quelques années selon lui il ne restera
plus rien de ce témoignage du passé